if someone was to write the perfect
crime what would mess up the forensics
person from that thing i always say
that's the number one question I get is
is what you do and i say lie and lie
first you get a big cast-iron tub you
put a body in it and you pour a lie over
until it's dissolved bodies will
dissolve bone at all and then if there's
somebody says have you seen Fred you go
no haven't you lie so lie and lie
however when the criminalists get there
and they examine the pipes and they go
why is there so much lie in the pipes
they're going to get on to you there's
no perfect crime no perfect crime we
will find a way it may take time but we
will find a way and as writers we will
find it in interesting ways is it easier
to write a script from a disorganized
criminals point of view versus it and
organized depends on the way you think
in your in your audience I personally
think it would be more fun to write a
disorganized because I like evidence and
red herrings and you can do anything
with disorganized oh I found this like I
said earlier a bloody fingerprint what
do you do with that you know you can
play with that stuff but red herrings
ago well it could be this it could be
that and you get more of that which
makes I think a better read this is for
novels of course it makes a better read
if you've got something disorganized
because you can go anywhere with it and
you don't know where you're going with
it organized pretty linear pretty linear
so it depends on what you're shooting
for
you